see so jess i can see your screen
and i could hear you well just a second
ago
so uh if you're ready
then uh please take it away great thanks
a lot just give me one moment to get my
technology in order
if that's all right
good so thanks a lot for uh the
introduction ryan and thanks to everyone
for attending
um so yeah this is some joint work with
siddhanth who's going to give the next
talk in a moment and with prosecutor who
i think is
somewhere out there in the in the crowd
and
um so the you know the theme of this
workshop is computational phase
transitions and i think this will be
quite uh in the pocket of that so so
since we're early in the workshop let me
give just an overview of the
problem set up that i'll be working on
so um
we're working kind of a beijing
inference setting where there is some
null model
which outputs random noise and a planted
model
which outputs some sort of interesting
signal that's been corrupted by the same
sort of random noise that the
null model generates and we observe
the output of one of these two things
and we have to decide which is which
and the details of the planted model are
known to you the practitioner and
the algorithmic algorithmic task here
it's just to see the sample and decide
with high probability which model it
came from
so um decide
null versus planted
with probability 1 minus little of one
okay and um
so i'm not going to dwell on the
phenomenology of these models that's
been well developed
most of the people on this call but let
me let me just say a little bit
so in many cases there's a natural
signal to noise ratio and problems like
this that measures the strength of the
planted signal
so we can draw a little cartoon where
the signal to notice ratio is here
and it's getting larger so the signal is
getting stronger so initially there's
some impossible regime
where um where no algorithm
do this task and do this decision task
just because the models are too close
together
then we reach an information theoretic
threshold above which there's a sort of
hard regime
where polynomial time algorithms are no
good but maybe an exponential time
algorithm can do it
and finally at the computational
threshold above that
there's an easy regime where this
hypothesis testing problem is
solvable by all kinds of polynomial time
algorithms
so studying these information through
theoretical thresholds we have a lot of
tools to do this
right um sometimes it's technical and
very difficult
there's been lots of heroic work in the
past 20 years on
pinning down exactly what these are but
computational thresholds are somewhat of
a different animal right because we have
to reason about all possible algorithms
that could do this hypothesis testing
task
and we don't have great tools to do that
so what do we do instead well we like to
design good algorithms
that work as close to this threshold or
what we believe this threshold is as
possible
we also like to provide evidence for
hardness
which usually just means taking these
good algorithms and kind of beating up
on them showing that they don't work so
well
below this threshold or where we believe
this threshold is and today is going to
be in this
spirit
[Music]
so in particular what i intend to do
is propose a semi-definite programming
hierarchy
for generic inference tasks like this
so sdp hierarchy
so that in the same you know
in the same way as with some of squares
we can have a quite general and powerful
framework for studying different
reputation or certification or
optimization tasks
and we can work within this framework to
see how well it does and we have this
notion of how far up in the hierarchy
you have to go to
successfully perform the task um it
would be nice to have something like
this
for inference problems as well so that's
that's the purpose of today's talk and
um before i get into this fully general
hierarchy i first want to talk a bit
about
a particular problem which is community
detection and sparse random graphs
and some of the sdp approaches to that
problem and kind of show how
uh these motivate this more general
framework which
i think can be applied to lots of lots
of other things as well
any questions before i move on
okay
so okay let me be a little bit precise
about the model that we're going to be
doing
for community detection so the null
model here
is just the urges rainy model with
average degree d
and d over n
and planted model is going to be the
static block model
of course with n vertices k groups and a
signal to noise parameter that i'll call
lambda
so how does this model work well first
we choose
a partition of the vertices into k
groups and then the edges are
independent condition on these groups
so this is supposed to be the sigma
edges are independent condition on sigma
and in particular in the parametrization
that i find kind of charming
the probability that an edge uv
appears in the graph conditional on
sigma
is 1 plus k minus
1 lambda times d over n sigma u
equals sigma v and that's
uh excuse me 1 minus lambda
times d over n otherwise
okay um and
one reason to parameterize the model
like this is that it's really easy to
write down
a clean expression for the conjectured
computational threshold so the easy
hard transition
is conjectured to take place when d
lambda squared here is equal to one
because the statement threshold this is
called um
and there's been lots of work on this
already um
that i'm not going to dwell on too much
but let me just say that
you know it's well known that this
conjecture holds for belief propagation
and for spectral methods
um these particular specular spectral
methods based on the non-backtracking
matrix or things like it
um and this is work of macel
nieman and sly um
a large masuya masouli
and lots more um
so this is great we have some algorithms
that we know are good at this problem
and we'll know that they fail
about where we expect them to but
today i promise to talk about
semi-definite programs so so what it
does
what about sdps
so to set up the the stp stuff
um let me let me define a matrix and
i'll write it in pink because it's going
to appear throughout the talk so
let's define a matrix xuv where if i've
drawn a graph from
the planted model this is just a
nice matrix representation of which
vertices are in which groups
in particular xuv is going to be 1 sigma
u
equals sigma v and that's going to be
minus 1 by k minus 1.
otherwise
um and you can check that x is a psd
matrix it's just the gram matrix of some
nice
vectors pointing to the corner of a
simplex um and also that x
u u is equal to one for all u since
every vertex is in the
same community as itself
so um why have i told you about this
matrix well here's
a little lemma
you can you can check on your own time i
think it will
not be super illuminating to have me
perform this calculation
you can check that the matrix inner
product between this matrix
and the centered adjacency matrix
is about d times lambda times n
plus order terms
so this is
in the planted model
so the idea once you know this is
to use this fact to design a
semi-definite program that is meant to
provide to perform this hypothesis
testing problem for you
so let's define sdp
of a minus
expected version of it expected uh
a this is just the supremum over all
matrices that have the same
general structure as x so psd matrices
ones on the diagonal of um
let's write it this way inner matrix
inner product of x
with the centered adjacency matrix
okay so let's define this thing
and then we're going to do hypothesis
testing
by comparing
sdp of a minus expected a
in null versus
planted models the virtue of this is
that in the planted model we already
know that there's some feasible solution
to this stp
that has a particular value for this
matrix inner product namely the planted
x that i drew in pink up here
and um so now to see how well
this sdp hypothesis testing idea is
going to work
we have to understand um
well how this sdp function behaves
when you give the input not from the
planted model but just from the null
model
expectation is that the expectation
under the null
um so either way the expectation is the
same right every edge has probability d
over end of appearing
yeah yeah
good so um speaking of here is a theorem
by
uh zubarata and andrea from a few years
ago which says that
under the null model this is how
this stp function behaves supreme
over all these matrices with the same
structure as our currently planted
matrix
x is uh two root d times n
plus a little lower terms in n and d and
so as the corollary
you can use right away use this use this
function and use this semi-definite
program to distinguish the two
distributions
whenever lambda is more than two of a
routine
so this is great um this is you know
very serious work and
uh it's a great paper um the the thing
to note about
this uh little corollary i've written is
that this is actually not
the ks threshold right which is kind of
interesting
um so uh they also show in in this work
that um when k equals two
and d goes to infinity um
the
uh this stp i can
perform uh the hypothesis testing
problem all the way down to the ks
threshold so
works down to chaos so it actually works
better than this corollary
that i've written and the reason is that
um the sdp value
in the planted model is kind of larger
than the planted
solution that it was intending to find
in the first place which is an
interesting kind of charming
feature of this proof um
but this does raise some questions so
one is
you know how do you how do you
generalize this to large k
or small d
um and the other is whether whether this
sdp although it's it's amazing that it
works in the case k equals
two and t going to infinity whether this
is the most natural stp
to do this problem um and the fact that
in the planted model the solution it's
finding
is actually better than the one that you
planted in the first place
it feels like an indication that this is
doing something
kind of special and different than you
expected so
if we go back to thinking about this stp
the interesting thing about it is that
it actually doesn't know very much about
the planted model at all
right it knows only this one lemma that
i proved on the previous slide
but it's it's not exploiting any other
possible structure
that x has beyond just the fact that
it's a psd matrix
and it's diagonal entries are one so
the idea uh for how to generalize this
is that in fact you should give the sdp
as much information
about the planted model as you can after
all you you're doing bayesian imprints
you know what the prior is
just throw in all of the all the info so
um let's and in particular this is going
to look like adding some aflan
constraints to this sdp
that you know are satisfied for the
planted x that you're actually looking
for
in uh in the planted model and so let me
let me tell you a little bit about
what good one good choice of of these
athlon constraints
so um let's say that gamma
is uh a non-backtracking lock
on the complete graph on end vertices
jess i don't see anything
showing up sorry here we go between
screens
is that better yep
great so yeah so let's say gamma is an
on that tracking block on the complete
graph on n vertices
and um uh let's define the weight of
gamma this is going to depend
on the random matrix that you're looking
at
this is product overall edges in gamma
of g e just the indicator that that edge
appears in the graph
minus d over n now let's define
a kind of weighted count of
non-backtracking rocks for these funny
ways
so i'm gonna make this matrix a bar
superscript
l um his uv entry is the sum
over all such gamma from u to v
non-back tracking in km
length of gamma is equal to l um of the
weight of gamma okay so this just again
counts these kind of centered weightings
of non-bad tracking walks
um it depends on the graph the random
graph
you're looking at and now analogous to
the proof of this limit from the
previous page
you can prove after all just for
instance
a 1 is just equal to a minus
it's expectation adjacent expectation
so we can prove a llama
without too much trouble that says that
if x is this
matrix that i defined from before
drawn from the planted model um then
matrix inner product
of these two things is about
d lambda to the l times n plus
smaller terms so the idea now
is to add
these affine constraints
to the sdp
so in other words you're going to look
for a psd matrix with the ones in the
diagonal
that satisfies all the outline
constraints so these are these are extra
features of this planted x that you're
looking for in the planted model and
your sdp is going to search for
a matrix that mimics this one and the
theorem is that
by taking l sufficiently large but
constant
this sdp that i've hand waved a little
bit here
can do detection
down to the ks threshold
and um in particular uh
in part two of the talk my board work
hasn't been great so i'll put this over
here
part two um sadante is going to show
that in the null model
this sdp function from up here
of these centered non-back tracking lock
counter matrices
it gives you something like root d to
the l times n
and you can check that as soon as you're
above the ks threshold this is much
larger
this quantity here then all of these
affine constraints are telling you it
should be
and so the sdt won't be feasible and
you'll be able to distinguish these two
distributions
so any questions about this went through
a little bit quickly so i'll have time
for a couple things afterward
just wondering about how the
relationship of l
where l comes in possibly it's like the
bigger l is like the closer you get to
the ks threshold
right exactly thanks for that question
ryan so um right so
so l here is kind of measuring how
strong the stp is right it's measuring
how much
information about the prior you've given
to it and the result is in fact that the
closer you want to the closer you are to
the chaos threshold the higher you need
to make l to be able to do
distinguishing
i'll ask another question too if you
know uh it's all right
um so this uh these constraints that you
added concern in some sense like certain
low-degree polynomials of the entries of
a
i mean and like it's like a very nice
choice i guess but um
this is a good like is it a canonical
choice is it like the best choice you
have any information about that
yeah so that's that's a very leading
question um
to leading into the next slide right so
i've set this all up to kind of kind of
tether this and earlier work on sdps and
community detection
and to illustrate this principle that
you um you can gain a lot by adding
extra information about the prior
into the stp but ryan's correct that
this is not
this looks a little bit ad hoc this
choice and it's not clear how we would
have
decided on this um and it turns out that
you can you can kind of find these as
natural choices
for the things for the ingredients for
your stp if you use a somewhat more
general framework
which is this framework i was hinting at
the beginning kind of a fully
general and flexible sdp framework for
doing inference problems
so let me let me say a little bit about
that
on the next slide here
okay so here it is
um right so this is this is now getting
into this local statistics algorithm
setup so um instead of talking about
community detection
let me talk about a very general setup
for inference
um that's going to look a little like
this
so let me be careful about this so i
have some
variables that i'll define first these
are set of variables x
which is x1 up to xn and
g which is uh g1 up to gm
and these are like variables that will
appear in polynomials because there's
variables and random variables i want to
be clear about what is which
so we have these variables they're going
to appear in polynomials and i'm going
to think of the null and planted models
as
random evaluations of these variables so
the null model is going to output a
random evaluation which i'll
try to write in pink g planted
it's going to output a random pair x g
and again you should think of x as kind
of a hidden signal
and uh g is the thing you actually get
to observe
um right so and let me let me also
assume
just just to kind of be completed here
um
that there's some constraint polynomials
that kind of describe the particular
combinatorial structure of
the outputs these random evaluations
that the models are generating so assume
there exists some constraint polynomials
q1
up to q k or something
such that q i of
x g is always zero so for instance these
could be polynomials that tell you that
the output is boolean or that it
you know has some particular norm or
whatever you like just some polynomials
that constrain the the form of your
uh your model
and now
let me tell you something that's not
going to seem useful at first but
that will be useful in a moment so in
the planted model
there's uh there's a nice map that we
can think about so
there exists a map that takes in
a polynomial in the x variables and
returns a real number
and this is just a map that sends a
polynomial p of x to its conditional
expectation
of x conditional on g
so this map has some properties
properties are going to look familiar if
you've done sos style things so
the polynomial one gets mapped to the
number one
um p q i gets mapped to zero
for any polynomial q i that's one of
these constraint polynomials
and any square of a polynomial gets
mapped to a positive number
okay this is just some conditional
expectation let me label these one
two three
um and i'll also note that in lots of
models that are interesting
these conditional expectations are kind
of well concentrated around their actual
expectations
okay
good so the idea here
is that you can
rule out uh
g having come from the planted model
by basically proving that no such map
no such conditional expectation function
can exist
by proving no such
conditional expectation
function can exist
okay
you want you want it to be linear i
guess this is suggested suggested by the
notation but you want this to be linear
right
linear yes please just can i also ask a
question that came from
nike son in the audience she says on the
right-hand slide
is it a true expectation or an sos
pseudo expectation
right so this that i've drawn right now
uh is i'm just pointing out that in the
planted model there is a true
conditional expectation which is just
literally send a polynomial to its
conditional expectation
the idea of course is that we're going
to rule out
the possibility of g being from the
planted model by showing that no such
actual expectation
can exist we're going to do that by
showing that no such suit of expectation
that can exist we're going to consider
sufficiently low degree polynomials
we're going to write down an sdp and
hopefully
if all goes well we're going to find
that that stp is not feasible
does that make sense
so here is the sdp local statistics stp
it has some parameters
dx and dg which are just degrees for the
x variables and g variables
and you're meant to find a suit of
expectation
from polynomials in the x variables
degree of most dx
to real numbers linear of course that
satisfies
one through three so it's normalized
it's uh respects these kind of hard
constraints
of your setup and it is positive
and moreover um
if p of x
g has degree
at most dg
in other words p is some polynomial it
depends on a low degree way on your
random instance then
we're going to add an alpine constraint
which says that the pseudo expectation
of p of x
evaluated at the instance you're looking
at is roughly the expectation in the
planted model
of the same polynomial in x and g
right and the idea is that this stp is
feasible
in um in the planted model by taking
this conditional expectation over here
and your hope is that it's going to be
infeasible in the null model
and that will give you a distinguishing
algorithm and these parameters dx and dg
are kind of degree parameters that tell
you how hard the algorithm has to work
to do this distinguishing task
and the setup here that i've written
down is
is quite general right this could be any
of your favorite inference problems
so this this is obviously inspired by
ideas of pseudo calibration and sos
and um later work of sam hopkins david
stewart
um applying that to inference problems
in a slightly different way
um but uh this this is kind of the the
main
tool that we wanted to propose in these
talks so the way that we found
these polynomials on the previous slide
is by actually trying to analyze this
local statistics algorithm and
finding the statistics that seem to be
cropping up as
important ones in our analysis
so let me end before i pass it on to
siddhanth
let me just end with a couple of main
results
so for this task of distinguishing the
artist rainy and stochastic block models
above the ks threshold the local
statistics works
for some degree in the graph in degree
in the instance that is
that it's constant the constant is
getting large as you get close to the
threshold
um and we proved that by showing that
simplified stp from a few slides ago
works and that basically that's that stp
is kind of captured by this this larger
framework
um on the other side on the lower bound
side we show that
if you're below the kf threshold this
simplified stp fails
and we think that this is the main
technical task that's needed
in proving that the full local
statistics algorithm
fails but there's there's some
additional technical details that we
haven't yet worked out
however we do have kind of a more
complete result in the deregular case so
this is where you want to distinguish
the regular random graph from a regular
version of the stochastic block model
and here um the local statistics
degree two in polynomials and degree
constant and
graph instance is um fully capable
of solving the detection problem above
the kf threshold and
completely fails below it so this is
nice evidence for hardness now
i should point out that this works for
all numbers of groups and all degrees
and it also is uh is possible to do it
in the case where the groups have
unequal sizes
and the kind of edge probabilities are
inhomogeneous so the fully fully general
spm7 which is nice
so i'm going to wrap up there and pass
it to siddhanth and let me just remind
you
what he's going to be doing in his talk
so we've we've kind of done this
big picture local statistics thing and
now there's some nice technical things
came up
in our proof of just the sbm stuff that
savant is going to get to so
he's he's going to be showing in his
talk um this fact here which is that
supremum overall psd matrices are the
ones in the diagonal
of this matrix inner product
between this
excuse me between the center non-metric
walk matrix
and um the variable in the stp
is about root dbs times n and this is
going to prove the kf threshold behavior
for
this simplified stp so i'll pause there
um
i guess i can take questions now and we
can also uh
thanks just one uh we'll applaud for
both of you jointly at the end perhaps
and perhaps while you're switching
slides you can answer
just you can answer a question from the
audience from anna thomas maybe also
disable your screen share
she asks uh can you summarize how this
hierarchy compares the sum of scores
hierarchy and other hierarchies such as
the kikuchi
hierarchy yeah absolutely so um
right the i i haven't thought too hard
about the
relationship between it and the kikuchi
hierarchy which is
really great at work that i've been
meaning to understand better for a while
um however uh in in terms of some of the
squares i can
say some things right so sos is is
kind of first and foremost a device for
reputation or optimization
so i show you just the null model for
instance and i want to rule out
the fact that there's a large cut or
that it's colorable with k-folds or
something like that
um so sos is great at doing this but
there's not there's not kind of a direct
way to use
sos for hypothesis testing you have to
do something like
pick some feature of uh the planted
model that the null model doesn't have
and write down a relaxation which rules
out that thing
but that's kind of a prior free task
right it doesn't actually
uh depend on what's in the planted model
it just depends on whatever particular
statistic you're thinking about
so you can use the sos to do refutation
and
do um try to do hypothesis testing with
reputation but this isn't always the
right thing to do so this is basically
tailored towards
adding all of your kind of nice basic
information about the two distributions
you're trying to distinguish this local
statistics is
i think later in the week we're going to
hear some from aconso about
the the perils and pitfalls of trying to
do
hypothesis testing with reputation and
the relationships between reputation and
various different
hypothesis testing problems
thanks jess uh let's continue with
siddhant
yeah thank you for the introduction ryan
and thanks to all the organizers